Um, anything exciting happen at the HUB?
I shot a superior officer in the chest.
Hey youtubers, it's Charlie. This week on Agents of SHIELD we got a big guest star
Victoria Hand from the MCU.
The science team took the lead again. And
we got some more backstory on Skye.
So let's talk about our favorite moments
and then I'll do my review.
First off, Simmons' spycraft and Simmons' Sandwich-Craft. She is the true genius of this episode.
Since these guys are the science team they
basically get most of the comedic roles.
And they were
totally up to the challenge in this
episode. Next up, Coulson VS
Victoria Hand. If you're not familiar with
the character from the MCU,
she rose to power during Norman Osborn's
to her at the head of SHIELD.
Or whenever it became HAMMER. She's loyal to Nick Fury and SHIELD but you can think
of her as like an evil version of
Cobie Smulders Maria Hill. Like they said during the episode several times,
"Trust The System"
They said it so many times, it basically
let you know that you're not supposed to
trust the system.
It's part of the Winter Soldier plot but
this stratification of information and these
levels 7, 8...
I'm sure all the way up to 10, basically
make it so that people can get away with
things and
everyone else won't find out. By the time
we get to Winter Soldier in the spring
that basically will be the plot.
Captain America and Nick Fury trying to
get rid of that element inside of SHIELD.
But without the culture of secrecy we
would not have had that Simmons spycraft
moment, that was so amazing.
I'm totally hoping that Simmons gets to
go on more field missions in the future.
Skye learned a little bit more about her
backstory but not at the expense
of Ward and Fitz, so I think she
really is back on Team Coulson.
I think a lot of people wondered about
her loyalty after she betrayed the team
in that previous episode, but
moments like this where she basically
stops and thinks about others before
herself
really lets you know that she does care about
all these people. But all in all, my favorite
moments were Fitz and Simmons moments. I
tend to think more of
the comedic and you know, character
interaction moments that I do the action
sequences.
there are few ridiculous action
sequences I'll talk about during my
review that I didn't really care for.
But the really big question after this
episode, "Who is going to post that pesto
sandwich recipe online?"
It would not be a Marvel show though if
they did not reference big things from
the MCU.
So, Black Widow, Hawkeye and the Triskelion got big name drops during the
episode.
Hopefully we will see the Triskelion
during Captain America the Winter
Soldier, just because it's
such an epic thing that'd be way too
expensive to show during a TV show.
But I don't think we will be seeing Hawkeye
or Black Widow on Agents of SHIELD
anytime soon either.
In reference to Skye's backstory,  because we saw that dead woman in that final picture
I think that that was actually Skye's
mother.
That means that her father could
actually be a Villain. So I'm guessing
that SHIELD agent that dropped her off was
actually sent to kill them
on a mission. The jury's still out on the
true identity of her parents
but remember that date 1989 that was
what she was looking at so
think about big Marvel villains that
were active in the comic books during
1989.
Speaking about the big references, the
big Thor crossover is next week.
That episode is going to be directed by
Jonathan Frakes from Star Trek The Next
Generation, so I'm
totally hoping for some hilarious Star
Trek references. Be sure to SUBSCRIBE to
get my video.
I think some other complaints against
the show in the first couple episodes
were is that it was kind of avoiding a lot
integration with the larger MCU.
Either because it was trying to set
itself apart or it just didn't want to get too
bogged down in a lot of the canon.
But I think they listened to a lot of
notes, so I think we will start seeing a
lot more references to larger things
going on in the MCU from now on out.
But what did I think the episode? Overall I rate it a "B". I'm totally loving Fitz and Simmons
right now they are my favorite
characters on the show after Coulson
and May.
Compared to them, Ward and Skye really just
seem like the most boring characters ever.
So I'm really hoping that changes in the
next couple episodes because those
two characters just don't feel like they have
the back story or the relationship that
Fitz and Simmons have.
One of my few complaints against the episode was that the jet rescue at the end was
just a little too
over-the-top. It was just a little too ridiculous.
Using the jet stream to blow characters
around on screen.
But like I said, I really did like that
they're starting to work in Marvel
movie Marvel MCU plots
into the show. But forget about that Winter Soldier plot for now because next week
the Thunder is coming!
I don't think we'll be having a Thor
cameo, but the story will work with the
story from Thor The Dark World so it'll
be a lot of fun.
Don't forget I'm also doing a bunch of
special Doctor Who programming this week.
Right now you can click here to find out
about that and click here to learn
all about Agents Of SHIELD this season.
Thank You so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow, High Fives!